we say the facts we give our elves and
our w's right so real talk man we put
our invite if y'all want to talk [ __ ]
come back in the studio we'll talk about
it or we can box about it too
cause i'm in the gym now you're feeling
me i'm feeling feeling nice right now
that's a box of preach bro
that's what i got
no no but like no but like real talk man
like if we're gonna have this discussion
we're hotter than you [ __ ] straight up
and we work harder than you guys we put
out all different types of content we're
just out here reacting like man look the
[ __ ] out of here bro
we're not and later on in the video
you're saying that you wanna box with me
sort of happened that i'm going to be in
the u.s next week
you want to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] let's
go
both of you i'll be in us
next [ __ ] week hold up hold up i'll
let's go we'll put gloves on because not
only this that's why i have a problem
now you talk [ __ ] about my wife this
[ __ ] preachers married prior to a
[ __ ] beluga whale somewhere and y'all
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] and you talk [ __ ]
about my country old [ __ ] said that he
was about to send me on a boat to my
country to haiti yeah
cool
next week
i'll be in i'll be in the states
i'll drop by your [ __ ] studios you
know where it is give me the address
i'll be right there don't come
unprepared we'll do it you want to do
this
let's go
we'll put gloves on it'll be illegal i
know florida lies i take one [ __ ] then
i take the other one
let's go
let's go you want to talk to me i'll be
there okay you know what i wasn't there
last time
i wasn't
but now you want to do this
you want to you want to set up the box
let's go okay
both of you [ __ ] let's go hey you
want to do this
let's go
i'll be there yeah he's just gonna do it
from okay
cool yeah next week i'll be there okay
listen at the end of the day listen i'm
not here to have people fight not
advocate but
preach you your own man that is not me
go [ __ ] i did not say that i had no
problem with it you're gonna bring my
wife and you're gonna be my country in
this no problem braden
let's do this i promise you i promise
you fresh is not about that life i don't
care [ __ ] this [ __ ] is not about that
you have to understand that when you
talk some [ __ ] there's consequences
let's do it i might lose this whole [ __ ]
not a problem i'll be there next week
i'll dm you guys we'll set it up we
don't have to do this back and forth we
can set it all up we don't have to do
all this talking yapping just let me
know what kind of gloves you want 14
houses 16 ounces or the hard banger mma
fighters gloves just let me know because
i got three of them and if you [ __ ] out
after doing all that chippy chatting if
you [ __ ] out
don't come to talk to us about anything